well the Lindsey Graham's Bill does is  it bans abortion after 15 weeks which  has many on the right have pointed out  as Lindsey Graham pointed out accurately  so this just puts the United States  right in line with most European  countries most civilized countries  across the world 15 weeks  you know my my wife is a little bit more  than 15 weeks but she's right around  there  I mean 15 weeks is late  it is late into a pregnancy  and at 15 weeks now you don't have uh  unborn babies who are viable in the  sense of we say viable meaning you can  take them out of the womb and they can  survive completely on their own  but they are developed like recognizable  human beings you look at the ultrasound  of 15 weeks and you will see little  babies there  so it's a moderate  bill  but Democrats are taking the gifts that  they've been given and um  painting it like this extreme attack on  quote unquote women's rights